The Grand Canyon.
Enormous,
iconic,
breathtaking.
2019 marks Grand Canyon National
Park's 100th anniversary.
But how did it get to be
such a beloved destination.
Archeological artifacts
suggest that people lived
in and around the canyon
some 12,000 years ago.
Today, it's still
considered a sacred place
to 11 Native American tribes,
despite being moved on to
reservations in the 1800's.
The United States didn't
really explore the area
until the treaty of Guadalupe Hidalgo
seated over 500,000 square
miles of land to the US.
Including the Grand Canyon.
So, in 1857 the US
government sent an expedition
led by Lieutenant Joseph Ives
to explore the Colorado River.
While Ives admired the scenery
in his report he wrote,
"The region is, of course,
altogether valueless.
"Ours has been the first, and
will doubtless be the last,
"party of whites to visit
this profitless locality."
History proved Ives wrong,
but throughout the late 1800's
companies struggled to
make the area profitable.
And few were considering
this harsh landscape
as a tourist destination.
Even so, President Benjamin Harrison
saw the need to protect
this inspiring place,
and created the Grand Canyon
National Forest Reserve
in 1893.
The Grand Canyon's popularity
grew tremendously after that.
In 1901, a new rail line ran directly
to the Grand Canyon Village
where most tourists, to
this day, start their visit.
A comfortable train ride, and
the brand new El Tovar hotel
enticed the elite class
to visit the Grand Canyon.
Including President Theodore Roosevelt,
during his 1903 visit he
emphasized the importance
of preserving the Grand
Canyon in a speech,
"Leave it as it is. You cannot
improve on it; not a bit.
"The ages have been at work on
it, and man can only mar it."
And, in 1908 Roosevelt
declared the Grand Canyon
a national monument.
During this time, more visitors made use
of the traditional Native
American walking trails
like, the Bright Angel Trail,
for mule rides and hiking.
And more people meant more lodging.
Architect Mary Elizabeth Jane Colter
was hired to design many of the parks
most iconic buildings.
Her ground breaking
work earned the nickname
Grand Canyon's architect.
And finally three years after
the National Park Service was created.
On February 26th, 1919,
President Woodrow Wilson
signed the Grand Canyon National Park
into law, making it the
nation's 17th national park.
Over 37,000 people visited
the newly enshrined park
in its first year.
Today, the park has hosted
more than 211 million guests.
But all this momentum led
to some growing pains.
Commercial flights,
which were gaining
popularity in the 1950's,
would treat passengers to
a view of the Grand Canyon
while en route to their destination.
This led to disaster in June of 1956
when two commercial planes
crashed over the Grand Canyon,
killing all 128 people on board.
It was the deadliest aviation
disaster of the time,
and motivated congress
to regulate the then
largely uncontrolled skies.
The 21st century has brought
its own set of challenges.
Helicopter tours have increased so much,
that a part of the canyon
has been nicknamed helicopter alley.
And development companies are proposing
new retail and lodging,
which might interrupt the
natural beauty of the canyon.
But, conservationists and Native Americans
are fighting to preserve the
natural integrity of the park,
just like they have in the past,
for future generations to enjoy.
Through it all, the Grand Canyon
has solidified itself in the hearts
and minds of Americans.
And to this day, it's
one of the most visited
national parks in the country.